if you're not a person of faith please
use these few moments
uh to think and reflect in your own way
let's pray creator god
as john chairs this important meeting
this morning called its short notice
we thank you for everyone who has been
able to rearrange their busy schedules
to be here this morning
as this council considers its
responsibility to the planet
and to future generations and also
considers getting ready
to embrace the new reality of what daily
work
will look like in a post covered world
we pray for great wisdom and insight for
both officers and councillors alike
that they may be of one mind on these
matters and reach complete agreement
uh united in their vision for the future
help them together to discern what is
good and helpful and right
creator god your word tells us that the
natural world is groaning
longing for a cleaner better day to come
and that all good work is pleasing to
you in and of itself
forgive us for the ways in which our
work has caused damage and not repair
help us all to work in such a way that
both the planet
the whole community and even family life
are given the space to breathe and to
thrive
to be restored and made new
we thank you for hearing our prayers
feeding us with your word
and encouraging us in our meeting
together in jesus name
amen amen thank you mark i
see that we are live streaming now on
youtube uh beth could you carry the roll
call please
counselor austin
councillor bradford president
council bill event
council david cox
councillor hugh cox present
council of doors
he's on his way thank you councillor
dewhurst
apologies present councillor eden
councillor evans president
councillor foden present
cancer goodman bradbury present
cancer gribble
gordon hook present cancer jackie hook
present cancer jefferies
present that's a jinx
present
mcgregor
got some organ present
that's the malone present
catson nutsley present
cancer orm
cancer parker card presents cancer patch
present cancer pit
council linda pedrec president
council fitz president
cancer president council of rolison
cancer swain
council taylor presents cancer thorne
present cancer tomb
councillor wrigley isn't
cancer parker present that's john
pedreck
president
thank you are there any apologies for
absence please
yes i've had apologies from a counselor
and nuttel
jeffrey and russell
okay thank you
uh just gonna go back one step now to
meet in protocol and this is something
that i mentioned before every meeting
but this chairman
i i miss the roll call i am present
married
thanks thank you coach thank councillor
cargo thank you very much
uh meeting protocol um uh please members
keep your microphone on mute if
you are not speaking and please to keep
the camera on during the actual meeting
if any of you wish to comment on on on
the agenda item that we're gonna
hear today then please raise your
electronic hand and you will
actually go into a queue and i will be
able to identify who the first in the
queue is and so on
so um that will be dealt with fairly
and if if by any chance we do need to
take a toilet break a comfort break then
i think that would be about an hour and
a half into the meeting
are there any declarations of interest
i take that as a no item three on the
agenda
is forward house decarbonization and
agile working project
this is detailed on the agenda pages 3
to 18
of the agenda i'd like to ask no the
member for
climate change to move the
recommendation please
good morning members um thank you chair
um i don't intend to go into the detail
of the report before us
but myself and officers present are
happy to take any questions on the
detail of the report
which hopefully you found time to read
rather i just wanted to set the context
for the two interlinked elements of this
report
you'll remember that in april 2019 this
council
unanimously declared a climate emergency
and in so doing it committed to doing
all within its powers
to ensure our council and the district
was carbon neutral by
2025. i think we all recognize how
immensely challenging that target is
there are so many aspects of the
district's carbon footprint that are not
within this council's direct sphere of
influence
where we need to work with others to
achieve carbon reduction
and many areas in which we need to lobby
central government for better
legislation
we are doing both of these however when
we made our declaration and signed the
devon climate declaration
we committed to lead the fight within
our district by addressing our own
carbon emissions
as an organization that would have been
extremely difficult without having a
dedicated qualified officer
to take forward that work and we have
been very fortunate to have the services
of
will elliot and will joins us today it
is well together with the team of
supporting officers at team bridge
who submitted the boots to the public
sector decarbonisation fund earlier this
year
we have already reported our success
with the decarbonisation bid for our
leisure centers
but recently we were also informed of
our success with the bid relating to the
decarbonizing of fordhaus
and i wanted to take the opportunity to
thank will and all those involved with
putting the bid together
and subsequently putting this report
together
especially andrea in finance
as we've seen before the time scales
with regards to some of these government
funding bids are extremely challenging
and officers involved to pull
have pulled out all the stops to ensure
that we can get back to the funders
with the information and approvals they
require
the need for this extraordinary meeting
today is because the funding
administrators
need us to achieve full council approval
before we have the next scheduled full
council meeting
this funding provides us with a
fantastic opportunity
to reduce the carbon emissions of ford
house by over 90
the works are indicated in appendix a
and include the replacement of the
gas-fired heating system
with air force heat pumps replacing the
extract ventilation system
installing draught proofing and
installation of an
insulated roof in addition
to these grant funded works more solar
pv
will be added to the building as well as
achieving carbon reduction
the council will see a large reduction
in energy bills
amounting to over seven thousand pounds
per annum as a result of these works
whilst the purpose of the bid funding
was to decarbonize the building
it would have been remiss of us not to
also consider other changes
that could be made to the building at
the same time
to take advantage of the scope for
reducing the amount of office space
occupied by the council
recognizing the increase in homework in
that is likely to take place
post covered considering agile working
was also part of our climate declaration
commitment
but covid as a contributory influence on
that
means that it makes absolute sense to
consider now
adaptations to the building that can be
made at the same time as the
decarbonization work
to ensure not only efficient energy use
and lower emissions
but how we can enable more flexible
working spaces
and take advantage of the release of
some office space to rent out
and create an income i should add that
since the report was produced
last week there has been ongoing work
with acom
the contractors on the detail of the
agile working component of the works
the result is that costs have been
reduced
such that a change in recommendation 2
has
has been included today um
this has a lower borrowing needs figure
approximately 350 000 pounds less
in cost so the new figure in
recommendation two
in replacement to the figure there of
approximately 2.7 million
the new figure should read 2 million 368
031 pounds um so that's that's a good
news story
as a result of the ongoing work on the
project
um so i hope councillors will approve
the three recon recommendations
outlined in the report with the slightly
amended recommendation too
allowing us to get on um with this work
without delay
thank you thank you councillor jackie
hook
uh proposal from councillor hope would
somebody like to second that proposal
please
councillor gary taylor thank you
councillor taylor
uh councillor sarah parker khan
thank you um i've just got a couple of
questions really about the proposal
um just just a few details first of all
if you would please um one is around
where the staff have been consulted
about agile working
obviously with the reduction potential
reduction of office space
and have they been asked or any
consultation being made around whether
they want to
have this flexi working model and what
the feedback was like
and my second question would be
obviously the ground floor currently is
occupied by
revenue and benefits and that's where
the public make their first point of
call
do we have the assurance that public
will still be able to come and access
in-person revenue and benefits at ford
house
or is it going to be located elsewhere
so we'd like to respond sorry yeah sorry
i wasn't sure if you were going to um
yeah i will
i will pass that over to neil or the
appropriate officer thank you
councillor taylor
thank you thank you very much uh jay yes
i'm very happy to
uh to to second uh this proposal
uh i think it's uh it's really something
certainly something like that i've been
very keen that we do at fordhaus since
since we uh
since this new administration uh came to
power
two years ago um we need to invest
uh these funds so that we can reduce the
the
the carbon footprint of forward house as
soon as possible rather than
rather than wait for things to wear out
which although the
as i understand it the the gas boiler is
worn out and due to bit and due to
need replacement uh having taken a
different a difficult
this difficult step my myself in a
much more modest modest way um
to be to be honest i don't think that we
would we would look back as an authority
uh within with any regrets at all about
going and going all electric gives us so
much so more
so much more flexibility in terms of our
heating and cooling
which is uh needed in our office spaces
uh
now um welcome to the 350 000 pound uh
reduction in additional funding uh
that's required
um and i think it's quite an exciting
proposal regarding the the agile working
and how we can make forward house
that much more efficient uh for for the
benefit of our taxpayers
let's face it at the end of the day is
it it is uh
the the local taxpayers who
ultimately fund the the the running of
forward house and i think
you know they would they would be
pleased to see that we are managing
their funding uh in a responsible uh
in a responsible way uh both in terms of
the environment and in terms of
the the funding so so i fully support it
i
i also agree with with sarah
council parker khan regarding the
accessibility i i would be good to
understand
um how that will be taking place and i
look forward to hearing the officers uh
report on that thank you councillor
taylor before i invite the next member
to speak just for clarification please
some democratic services
i noticed that a member was has joined
us shortly after the agenda item
actually started so
am i correct in assuming that that
member will not be able to vote but
we'll be able to comment on the agenda
item
you just had the introductions chair
would be up to the member to
um decide whether he's had felt that
he's listened to the debate enough
sorry chair i did join the meeting after
the uh
after the beginning of the meeting but
before this agenda item are you talking
about me
okay my apologies i am here and was here
for the beginning
i just thought i would clarify that one
okay the next german excuse me
i wasn't here for the roll call but i
was here for the beginning of the
meeting okay thank you councillor as
well
nobody else came to the doors
i i'm assuming you were talking about me
and i was here for
not the roll call but the start of the
agenda item
no no i wasn't actually counsel doors no
but carry on please
okay so uh i'd wholeheartedly support uh
anything uh that the council does to
reduce its carbon
carbon impact and uh i think it's a a
small step in the right direction what i
would like
uh us to do is uh think on a much bigger
scale and think a lot more creatively
um we're facing the biggest existential
crisis
uh the the humankind's ever faced so
uh this might sort of scratch the
surface what i'd like uh the council to
commit to doing uh in the future is to
actually look at the
the need for for so many in-person
meetings we're going to be told the
government dictate that that should be
done
but we should at least uh have an impact
study of all the travel that he's done
unnecessarily in in lots of cases lots
of
members don't turn up and don't even
speak at meetings
uh i think the crisis has shown us that
there is a great
utility in using technology that can
have a massive massive
impact on on our carbon footprint as a
council
uh and then more overarchingly i think
uh the we can show a lead by
demonstrating
that having the utility of a huge space
in the center of a town
maybe we could have some more creative
thinking of what we do with that and if
that's multiplied across the
across the country it would have have
huge impacts i'll throw in one great
suggestion perhaps we could book
uh council meetings into the newly
refurbished grade two listed alexander
theater
when that that project eventually uh
goes in the right direction so
i will lend my support to this motion
and i'd like the council to commit to go
an awful lot further in the future
thank you thank you councillor dawes
councillor hocking
uh thank you chair mine's a very simple
question um
we have in the report um the amount of
borrowing that the council is going to
do
and it states that uh you hope to
provide a minimum of one percent return
on our investment
does that does that include
the money the um interest that we have
to pay on
on the borrowing or is that will that
come out after
the one percent return thank you
uh would somebody like to field that
question please
can i can i just make a few comments and
i'm sure officers would want to join in
um the answer to mike's question
i i believe is yes but we'll we'll um
get passed to finance in a minute but i
just wanted to agree
absolutely with the comments um from
councillor doors we should
be looking to maximize the use of
technology for virtual meetings i'm sure
most of us would agree with that i
certainly have found virtual meetings um
a much more efficient way and use of my
time and
i'm sure a lot of us don't want the
travel involved in going to meetings so
if even if we can't hold council
meetings um
virtually i hope we will continue to
maximize as many
numbers of meetings as we can other
meetings um
held virtually and get the technology
technological capability to do that
um so certainly agree with that one um
can i pass to the i think those three
sets of questions sarah's questions
um richard dawe's questions and mike
hawkins
thank you okay thank you
councilman
uh thank you very
that was my much but there wasn't a
response but yeah please please do
yeah neil or somebody yeah yeah sorry um
okay i was waiting for the pause
um so i'll pick up uh councillor khan's
questions
um obviously the staff a lot of majority
staff have been working from home
um since march last year and there's
been ongoing discussions
um initially about the return to the
office
and having the covert secure workplace
to make sure there was no more than 50
occupancy
um and as part of that we've been
looking at the balance of
uh working from home working within the
office for those who need to come in
so some of these discussions looking at
agile work and is based on those
those themes and those approaches and
there's been an ongoing discussion with
staff to understand how that's working
for them what improvements need to be
made
to improve working from home
because it's obviously initially it was
a reaction to
to what we needed to do um and people
have made do
but obviously there needs to to be a
permanent solution it needs to have a
lot more investment
and thought into that so those
discussions have been ongoing
um and subject to uh the funding being
agreed
um more detailed work will be done on on
the planning but there is ongoing
discussions now with all
um staff about what the needs are what
the service requirements are as well as
the personal needs
and that will continue as as the project
moves forward
so the staff are engaged in this work
and you're the question related to the
ground floor accessibility for
revenue and benefits and my
understanding is it will still be
accessible how it works will be part of
the design
process um again subject to fund and
being agreed
and the project being developed further
as to how best to provide
those services so it's a to be continued
answer really on that one
um for councillor dawes this question um
was that on the
reducing the need to travel
unnecessarily um
side of it can i just get clarification
please counselors are shaking his head
in agreement
yes yes not in my head yes that's right
yes um obviously virtual meetings
will require legislation from government
um the last legislation's run out and
they didn't renew it so
um obviously you have to go back to
in-person meetings uh i think there's
there's been a lot of support
um for virtual meetings and the benefits
they've brought in a lot of ways
so that's something that we'll need to
um obviously
lobby towards if we want to see that
change and looking at alternative uses
for buildings and
um is something that we'll always
continue to do of what opportunities we
can make to
to reduce travel we're looking in-house
at how we we deal with that and reducing
the need to travel and
as initiatives come along and
opportunities arise that's certainly
something we'll
um we'll continue to push i think the
final question is probably
if i can pass over to martin on the
finance questions after k martin
yep happy to answer that one so um in
relation to council mike hocking's
question
um the one percent return is after
paying any interest
on any loans that we have to take out
and it's also
after any repayments of capital as well
so it covers a repayment
of capital costs as well thank you
thanks for the clarification council
malone
thank you um councillor hook's uh
presentation points to a yearly saving
uh of energy costs of 7
000 pounds per year um
forgive me because i'm clearly uh
comparing apples to oranges slightly
but if if a normal person would try and
uh
make their own house carbon neutral then
even with a sort of belt and braces
approach they could expect to recoup
the money uh for those
um improvements in in about 15 to 20
years
now this this figure even with uh even
with the new figure
and even subtracting the grant funding
we're looking at recovering the cost of
doing this in in about 320 years
um can we explain why
the uh why it would take such an
enormous time to re-keep the savings i
mean
obviously we'll never recoup the savings
um
is is what is the reason why the price
on price tag on this is so
so large please thank you
neil could you respond to that one
please
i i'll defer to either will or martin on
that one
um yes so there are there are two
main sort of income streams that we'll
achieve from these
decarbonization works and those are the
energy savings that you pointed out
cancel them alone
um but also there's the intention to
develop a new income stream from renting
out
um part of the ground floor to a tenant
and so that will
increase the rate of return on the
project um
the the reason for why the payback i
don't believe you quite as long as as
you
as you raise there but um the reason for
why that payback is so long is
is simply because um there's just a
number of
um investments that we need to make into
the building to make it ready for low
carbon technologies um so currently the
building
just isn't geared up for the um for the
type of heating system that we want to
put in
as we've had so we've had to make our
own further contributions in order to
make that system ready
so um examples include
installing a new electricity supply
system to the building
so superseding our existing supply and
installing an upgraded system that can
supply enough energy and power
to that new air source heat pump that we
connected to the electricity grid
um we'd also have to install suspended
ceilings because the heat will be
provided into the building
um at ceiling level um through sort of
blow
fan cassette units and that sort of
thing
um and there's there's a whole host of
works that we need to do to get this
building ready
um future proof and um decarbonized
thank you can i just add can i just add
some comments to that as well so
in terms of the running costs for
forward house
we also benefit by reducing our business
rate spill
um and some of the other recharges that
we make so so that that
does add to the return that we make
okay thank you come to the person
thank you chairman yes i i fully endorse
uh these proposals
and also very much endorsed councillor
dawe's uh
suggestions about virtual meetings it
does make life a lot easier and does
save an awful lot of carbon in terms of
travel
my question is around uh the rental out
of the ground floor
i just wonder could we understand what
work has been done
uh to assess what the likely demand is
for that
uh space uh when it's made available
and and do we have likely tenants lined
up or is that
very much in the future still
would somebody like to respond to cancer
person please
yeah sure i'll i'll make a start and
then
um steve foresees on the call if you
want to add anything further that i've
missed and then
he can do so um so we haven't got any
tenants
lined up right now um we've obviously
got other
units around that we've um we've got
office space
we know where the like the demand is
going to be
so we've looked at uh potential income
generation based on
comparable costs elsewhere and that's in
the report about
what would happen if we charged a high
level medium level or lower level
or or no rental received for a set
period of time
to see what's feasible what's realistic
and therefore what impact that has on
on the income coming back in um
obviously there's a lot of uncertainty
around a lot of elements of the rental
market at the moment
um as lockdown restrictions start to
ease
some businesses said they weren't going
to have office space
anymore there is still some demand out
there
for businesses that are looking to maybe
consolidate what they've got so they
might have quite a bit of office space
and needing to downsize to other areas
there are some
public sector um bodies that are looking
at alternative spaces at the moment so
there's different lines of inquiry we
don't have anything concrete to give you
now to say this is who's going to be
moving in
that work would carry on um
subject is subject to funding being
agreed um
if members sign this off today then then
the work will carry on to secure
tenants and understand what their needs
would be for the space available
stephen i've missed on that
sorry thank you i think you've picked
that up thank you neil um
just as as neil was saying basically um
we will make further enquiries with
public sector
partners that we have but also
as a full-back position clearly we there
are elements of the ground floor that
could be suited to small businesses as
well so
those lines of inquiry will be made at a
later date
thank you councillor patch
thank you chair i just wanted to follow
up counselor parker khan's question
which
which left a few um or rather the
response to which left a few questions
hanging in my mind firstly have staff
been formally presented with
plans or procedures or ideas for future
homework
with a view to getting their feedback
our views on that
and are formally presented with
proposals and if so what percentage of
staff
have expressed an interest in working
from home in the future
my concerns are mainly that well a
number of concerns really that
that while during the sort of
coronavirus
panic then lots lots of staff have
either been forced or
rather would have been quite happy to
work at home um
but with our restrictions being lifted i
i think for
a lot of employees then actually being
in an office environment
and interacting with colleagues the
social aspect of that
is very important and i think many staff
i can see
may be feeling a bit isolated if if they
feel they're pressured to
having to work from home so i i just i'd
like to know if there has been some
formal consultation on stars fuse and if
so what what percentage of staff are in
favor of these proposals thank you
councillor patch but the officers like
to respond please
uh yeah so in terms of a formal plan for
what will happen not specifically
there's been plans actual
floor plans of how desks may be spread
out
i mentioned earlier about the the
percentage of time
people are in the office so those
conversations have been happening
over the quite a few months on how these
things might work
understanding what the needs of the
service are and how people are working
we are incredibly mindful of
the impacts on isolation on staff's
mental well-being and
you know making sure that there is not
just the contact but also
where possible obviously kind of face to
face there's been quite a lot of
restrictions on what we can do
but we are very mindful of um the need
for
a lot of interaction uh in person that
creative element especially when you're
starting on projects and work and then
support
um so that has been an integral part of
our work over the last year
is supporting staff and making sure that
no one's been pressured
into into doing these uh making these
changes it's it's looking at
what works what works well um for some
stuff
they have more i guess needs than others
in terms of
the way what kind what work they're
focusing on
how much they need to interact with
others so it's an ongoing
engagement process so it's not being
railroaded through
for anybody there is ongoing
conversation
and looking at what the best fit is all
around
thank you come to the phipps
thank you chair if you can hear we've
got building work going on so if you can
hear any noise that's what it is
i apologize for that um it seems to me
that we're depending on them the rental
of the office space to pay back a loan
of some
2.6 million pounds is that the
is that the only income stream we've got
to pay back this money
is that what we are depending on because
um i'm a little bit concerned of the
viability of that
and i'd like to thank uh councilman for
putting the other questions for downtown
paris so they
stole my thunder a little bit but yeah
i'm just a bit concerned about
paying back this 2.6 million pounds
thank you martin would you like to
respond please
yes so the rental income is the major
stream of income that we get on this
project
so it is very much dependent on that um
but we have a considerable amount of
time from project start to finish to
identify a tenant so
um time will will tell us as to whether
we get a tenant or not we feel that
there's
going to be someone out there that will
want to rent part of all of that space
so we're fairly confident on that if we
get to a position where we can't rent
out then at that point we may have to
use further capital receipts to
fund the difference but that's the
position as we are at the moment
thank you thank you martin councillor
jackie hook
thank you chad i was just going to round
up in the end when people have finished
there's still other there there are
actually somebody coming back for us a
second uh
question uh councillor swain uh thank
you chad
um thank you also to all involved for
this
project for all the work that's gone
into it um i have a small question i'm
looking at the page 13 the
predicted carbon emission trajectory for
fordhaus
and i can see that um the gas
consumption is expected to drop right
off obviously
um by replacing that with an air source
heat pump
but i can't see on this graph where
obviously the air source heat pump is
much more efficient but it does still
use some electricity so we would
expect the electricity consumption to go
up and i can't quite see where that is
it does say increase in electric
electricity consumption for heating
offset by energy efficiency measures and
the solar pv
um which also leads me to a question
because um
is the solar pv sufficient to power the
heating system
the and in which case there's going to
be surplus a lot of the time but as i
understand it currently there's a
problem that where you generate surplus
pv you export it to the grid but you
don't get paid for it which is
quite a major problem with national
policy that really needs to be fixed on
an urgent basis
um are we expecting to be exporting
electricity for free are we installing
batteries
um can we get any more information on
that
um and uh i also wanted to mention
accounts for malone that was a very good
question about the payback period
um but as i understand the report the
existing gas heating system needs
replacing anyway so presumably
it's a choice between this scheme or
spending a lot more money on the old
system
it's not a choice between this scheme
and not spending any money at all is
that correct
uh thank you thank you councilman swain
i guess that the climate change officer
would like to respond to your questions
yes thank you councillor swing um
so i i think you're right to point out
that the graph doesn't appear to show
much of an increase in electricity
consumption
uh so that graph is showing the carbon
emissions from ford house
so the emissions are fact that the
emissions factors that have been applied
to each energy source
in that graph um they do sort of
disguise what's happening
underneath the surface and so you are
correct in this well the gas consumption
will drop off
entirely and we will see a net increase
in electricity
electricity consumption as a result of
connecting the heat pump
um but what we've taken into account is
a number of electricity offsets
associated with
the installation of the heat pump so
there are two major
areas where we can save electricity and
that's
um the first being would be
that we would um that we would remove
all of the auxiliary auxiliary loads
that's associated with pumping the hot
water to all the hot water radiators
around the building
so that's a fairly substantial source of
energy savings
um and then the second major source of
energy savings
is if you're familiar with the second
floor at fordham house
there are a number of splits air
conditioning units installed um in
various offices so these units uh
they're largely quite old units and
they're operating at quite an
inefficient level so once we de-install
those
those systems and supersede them with
this
much more energy efficient um heat pump
then we'll get some additional energy
savings from that
um so hopefully that answers your
questions about
um about the emissions trajectory
for for solar pv um if we were to
consider
the um net increase in emissions
sorry net increase in energy consumption
as a result of installing the air source
heat pump
the solar pv system should entirely
offset
that increase in electricity consumption
on an on an annual basis
um and then through investigation of our
existing and historical half-hourly
electricity consumption
we believe that we should be able to
capture the vast majority
let's say upwards of 90 of that
electricity generation because
our current genera our current
electricity demand is high enough to
absorb
that level of pv generation thank you
so that shouldn't be the issue of
exports the grid
thank you councillor linda thank you
thank you
you chair and we have declared a
climate emergency so i do think we need
to practice what we preach
but i also think it's really important
to keep the public informed in what
what we're doing and why we're doing it
because on the one hand we're telling
them that we've got a deficit
and then on the other hand we're saying
that we're going to borrow some money to
get
this work done so i think it's really
important about communication to the
public about
why we're doing it and and where we're
getting the money from
thank you thank you i see that three
members
have returned for a second question
sarah councillor parker khan
thank you and i completely agree with
what the last speaker
counseling linda pedrick said is that we
have to keep the public informed and i
don't think there's anybody here who
wouldn't agree that making the buildings
more efficient and decarbonizing isn't a
good thing
however our role is to ensure that the
proposals being put forward are the best
proposals
um and i just wanted to ask two
questions again
one was whether other alternative um
green means of technology for heating
the building had been explored
and and why they'd been discounted i was
thinking about biomass spoilers and
things like that and whether they would
be
as efficient or less um costly
and also i noted that the the government
funding i think it was 672
000 was contingent on particular time
scales
um and we're looking likely not to meet
those time scales and extensions have
been requested
i want to know what happens if we can't
meet the deadlines
even if it is june 22 22 and we have to
give the money back
is the intention that the council will
still compete pursue this course of
action
and we'll fund from elsewhere thank you
thank you councillor parker
i guess that the climate change officer
will be the first one to respond to one
of your questions at least
yes thank you councillor um so
we did consider other low carbon
alternatives
biomass that the there wasn't actually
grant funding available for
for a biomass solution um so our hand
was forced between
choosing between slc pumps and ground
source heat pumps
and in the end we sided with an air heat
pump um just because we're able to get
sort of more bang for our buck
from that grant funding
biomass we've explored that option in
the past as well but
given that this is an office building
and it doesn't have
a significant um year-long demand that
it means that this technology doesn't
lend itself quite so well
to this site so biomass works really
well um where you have a
um a continual demand for for heat
um it's biomass heating systems are very
much heat
driven systems um so one classic
example is um the biomass heating system
at dawlish
that site has a continual year-round
demand for heat um
and so it just means that that system
stacks up
especially when you when you couple that
with a renewable
uh with a renewable heat incentive so
unfortunately that scheme is no longer
available and we simply have to rely on
grant funding as it becomes available
in terms of project time scales um so
yes our time scales have exceeded
the september 2021 deadline but we've
we've been in regular
communication with salex the grant
awarding body
and they have said themselves they are
they're
cautiously optimistic that they will be
able to grant us a
a full extension um once the decision
comes through from central government
um they have also reported that other
councils are in the same boat
uh that we are um but it it does seem
very
um does seem very optimistic with that
we will get that extension
i think what's what's key to the
authority to de-risk
um de-risk um
the potential for grant funding to be
removed is to spend as much
of that grant funding as possible
ahead of the deadline and we're going
about this by
uh going down a route to the two-stage
uh project delivery process whereby we
appoint
a main contractor early for the project
and we place
early orders on the main equipment items
so this helps to accelerate
our spend um
and uh we are endeavoring as um
we are endeavoring also to um accelerate
the delivery of those projects as well
thank you thank you council malone
uh thank you um yeah i'm um
i'm i'm i'm i'm grateful for all the
explanations and i'm
as keen as anyone to have
low carbon buildings i just wonder about
the value for money for the taxpayer
ultimately because
i just wondered looking at this price
tag of over three million pounds has it
been considered
that we might be now that we're in the
frame of mind of
doing things remotely has it at least
been considered that maybe we should
just knock the whole thing down and
start again
because it's not an attractive building
it's not an efficient building
it doesn't have any sympathy to the very
important old building next to it
um why not start again for this kind of
price tag
and have something that is uh you know
zero carbon and is tailor-made for both
the council and the uh and the rental
possibilities
thanks you guys i'm sure that's an
option that's been considered
one of the officers like to respond
please
um i'm not aware that we've considered
the option of just knocking it down
and starting again so i couldn't give
you a costs but
it would be um i mean this site is a
former
landfill size so there's a lot of
remediation work
as a starting point along with all the
other costs of demolition and
replacement building um so i don't have
an answer to say what the alternative
cost would be
but it's not an option before us and you
would also have to relocate as well
during the
process wouldn't you yes yeah and then
perhaps just to add to that
you i think we also need to consider the
embodied emissions of the building so if
we were to scrap the building
we've got the emissions associated with
demolishing the building transporting
waste offsite
and then bringing new materials onto
site to develop a whole new building i
just think that we need to
um take
a more broader uh view on those
emissions we
can't just think about the operational
missions we need to think about the
emissions that's associated with with
those
with the uh with the construction of the
building as well
thank you councillor patch
thank you chair um i am i'm concerned
that
staff have not been formally consulted
on the
um on the on the plan for working from
home
in the future and i'm trying to
reconcile reconcile that in my mind with
the
uh view that no one is being pressured
um
given that if we um do lose lots of
space previously used by staff
in in the building and the majority of
staff or the vast majority do want to
come back and work
in the environment of forward house then
someone will know it will inevitably be
um pressured i just do wonder in my
mind's eye
whether it's um we might have a
situation where not only do we not
uh we're not able to attract someone to
hire the
um extra space that's freed up but we
might have staff
um who do not want to work from home and
what we actually end up
actually allowing those those staff to
come in and work in the space which we
previously planned to let out
um in a rather sort of counterproductive
move
um and in terms of the overall proposals
i want
is is it possible for us to split out
the
the upgrading of the heating system from
the proposed changes in working
practices
and layout of ford house because i would
think whereas i
i think um the majority of us would
agree that there's a need
and a benefit in upgrading the heating
system i think some
more time might be spent on thinking
through plans to
sort of rework the use of this space and
the andy
and the idea of staff working from home
i don't think we've got a firm view on
how that might um
pan out in terms of what staff would
like to do in the future
so it wouldn't be possible to take these
um set proposals separately
i'm not sure about that cancer patch
i'll need some guidance on that one
head of place would you like to respond
please sorry yeah sure i mean
the agile working bit it's i answered
the question about how they're being
sold on specific proposals before them
we're getting to that point there has
been discussions with staff
for the last year about agile work and
and
discussions about what's going to happen
going forward
on the whole i mean staff have been
engaged throughout
the last year on agile work and as a
concept
and on the whole it's been very positive
and even with the return to the office
which so we started
um august september last year
after the first lockdown had ended and
people started to come back and
government
gardens started to change on when people
couldn't come back
and on the whole that that split of
working from home and working in the
office was
viewed positively so i don't see
i appreciate the points council patch is
making the the staff are engaged
with the work the consultation will go
on on the detail once we've got
more certainty about what has been um
what we can propose because obviously a
lot of this depends on
uh the funding being secured and taken
the the earlier
the following point about can we
separate the agile work and from
the the funding result um not not really
um you know this relies we've mentioned
we're reliant upon the rental income
from the ground floor
um we are looking at uh
different ways of working and making
sure we make the best use of of this
building
by picking up on an earlier point uh
reducing the need to travel
is something that we will continue to
look at and some of that is the the
commute
to work so the proposals are taken as a
whole
um for this um there are
interdependencies between the agile
working and
the uh the decarbonisation elements that
it's not easily split
then if anyone else wants to to other
comments
i think phil wants to come in
cancer patch you also mentioned
something about the heating as well with
the climate change officer like to
respond to that one
you had a query about the heating as
well efficiency
sorry would you would you mind just
relaying that question again councillor
patch
i don't recall making a question about
the efficiency of the heating to be
honest
sorry you mentioned the heating i'm
sorry my mistake
so we'll move on then so uh cancel the
doors
thank you um i just wanted to follow up
on the
on the point race by councillor malone
actually because i think
i think it's a good one in terms of uh
the long
term plans uh i had direct experience
myself of trying to retrofit
a 1930s house and did everything i
possibly could in terms of installing by
my spoiler
uh mechanical uh ventilation heat
recovery system
uh and all sorts of insulation uh what i
probably should have done
uh is knock the house down and rebuild
it because i would have had a much
lower impact by doing that ongoing
um and uh and with all my best will in
the world
uh my by not doing that i i've created a
greater impact
because retrofitting it is very
difficult so if you
tie that into the trying to put a van
dave over a pre-existing building
alongside the fact that the the district
authority is a landowner in the middle
of town uh we have a huge housing crisis
uh we have land we have we're trying to
bring forward
uh land owners to to to satisfy
developers and and it's only farmers
seemingly
who can satisfy that uh there's an awful
lot of land around ford house that has
no utility at all i'm
one of the few people who runs through
the the from the front lawn
i never see any members of the public on
it um and
and i just think there should be some
blue sky sky thinking before we commit
to this
huge huge commitment which clearly has
no uh
economic viability to it it's because
there's a grant there uh and quite often
this council seems to be driven
because there's a grant there rather
than by doing the actual right things
so uh i'd like a little bit more
introspection
in this uh before we commit to it uh so
in fact i'm no changing my position on
backing the motion thank you
thank you council councillor taylor
yes uh yes i think council of doors is
slightly veering off subject here
but in terms of uh economically viable i
think we've seen
how we can make forward house more
economically viable
as regard to demolition i think that's
an argument that's reeled out
quite often forgetting of course in fact
the embedded energy
in in a building it would be some
many many years in the future where any
increased saving through demolition and
starting from scratch
would would be better than than actually
retrofitting
so i think for the budget that we have
and for the immediate impact that we can
have on the environment and i think
that's
something we should think very very
carefully about
to move forward as per this uh this
proposal
i think is the right way thank you just
as i thought we were bringing this uh
this matter to a close i see that a
flurry of hands have gone up
um counselor bulovant
uh thank you listening to the comments
from council doors and councilman malone
i think they make some interesting
points
um and you look at the payback that
councilman malone related to which is
over 100 years on this investment
and that's a very interesting and valid
point
particularly as that building as we all
know as you visited is
in quite a poor state and i think the
point that council doors makes about
replacing it
is something that really should be
considered um
i think uh spending three and a half
million pounds as a project
is something that the council could
afford to do but it should be spent in
the right way so i endorse what counts
as malone and doors have said
thank you thank you uh two more blue
hands just
so i'll go to the leader first i see
council mcgregor's put his hand up now
so the leader would you like to comment
please
oh thank you chairman i'm grateful to
everyone for
all of the various comments um it
strikes me that
uh the council had one nosy needs to
replace the gas boiler
and so we could just simply replace the
gas boiler at least cost
least change but something has to be
done so
doing nothing isn't isn't an option as i
understand it because the boiler
is at the end of its useful economic
life
consequently officers have seen an
opportunity to win a government grant
or a grant which would enable us to
do something which will reduce the
carbon which is a council commitment a
cancel endeavor
which would be better than a new gas
board head c
670 thousand pounds put some money to it
to to make that work as well
and then separate to that and learning
from everything that we've had
in the past year or so because of the
pandemic and lockdown
is to modernize the building to
facilitate agile working
and council patches right he said well
you know
will staff want to do that well before
pandemic i think a lot of staff would
have asked for um time away from the
office
if they thought we could do it and what
the pandemic has done is effectively
fast forwarded the the it that enables
that and i think a lot more people
are seeing the opportunities of that
flexible working where you spend
some days in the week in the office and
some days working from home
and not that i have direct experience in
it but through
other colleagues and other councils i'm
hearing of staff
who whereas they didn't apply for a job
at the council say some distance away
because i've had to relocate
what they're effectively doing are
working for other councils but staying
in their own house because they're
working
remotely and then going to their
um new council some distance away
occasionally for team meetings and away
from local government i have a friend
who lives in cornwall
who is working for forestry england in
bristol doing uh gdpr
data and the thing that's happened over
the past year
or so in my view is that that new style
of working has become more real for
people for
members of staff who are seeing the
opportunity so i'm glad that neil blaney
explained that we have been talking to
our staff closely
there hasn't been a formal consultation
but you know that is an ongoing process
and i think that
demonstrates the way i would have
expected it and shouldn't be a surprise
to staff
um and i can i can hear what people say
about well shall we just knock down the
building and start again
it's not the most fabulous building to
have next order a great one listed
and we can all look at planners of the
day as in members who made the decision
worse than but we also hear from
colleagues about what
that site is and the cost of demolishing
it
only the cost of demolishing it um
so i think really the choices it seems
to me as a ward cancer
are simply do we just replace the gas
boiler i've done
carry on or do we take the opportunity
that's before us now to
hit some of our climate change targets
and make the council fit for future
in terms of agile working and what that
may offer
not just our current staff but the
people we're looking to attract who may
for example want to work for team bridge
because we only require someone to be in
the office two weeks
two days a week and working for them
three days a week and that that suits
their lifestyle as well
and i think that's the way lots of big
organizations are going chair so
that's all i particularly wanted to say
i'm grateful for the
very good debate we're having on this
issue thank you thank you leader
councillor mcgregor
thank you chair um my apologies for
being late to the meeting i think i've
had a survey of fresh air in the last
few days and it it
it's basically got to me but the the
point of the points i wanted to kind of
cover really are that first of all ford
ford house itself
as we were probably all aware perhaps um
unconsciously was developing big swathes
of open space within the office and i
think this is a great opportunity
for team bridge to actually consolidate
its staffing
onto floors in an organized way
and create the space that it needs to so
that it can rent it out and this is a
great opportunity to do that
so um you know from the perspective of
of looking beyond
also the heating system this is also
this also includes the air conditioning
system which is
um elderly as well and probably
you know will require replacement at
some point in the near future
which is a further cost anyway so we're
looking to get all of those things done
within this project so we're creating a
working space for people together
so that people aren't isolated even
within the building
we're creating a better working
condition for people
and that's that's an improvement and
we're giving people the option to work
from home as well where they
are able to and feel it feel it's
appropriate for them so
all of those things consider i think
that that's actually quite a valuable uh
way forward yes the the the financing
looks like a long-term
uh investment and a long-term uh
recovery in terms of the
the funds coming back in but there's a
package of work for
all four sites that have been part of
the decarbonization
the actual carbon impact for the council
is phenomenal
it's a huge tick for us as a as a as an
authority
in terms of the amount of carbon
reduction that will will result from all
four projects going forward
and i think that really fits in well
with our policies on climate change
um and i think going forward again we
should be looking to
find further ways to reduce that uh on
on the last point and then this is a
point raised by council at doors and i
do appreciate that it is a big nice open
space but it's one of the most beautiful
open spaces
in that part of newton abbott ford house
law old ford house lawn
it's also a grade one listed property
and i think at this stage nowadays to
try and build around that
would potentially risk that that that
building and we
we are in a situation of course where we
are valuing
grade grade one and grade two listed
buildings in very different ways
by by looking at it in in that respect
and i think
retaining the the lawn that you can see
from brunel road
uh right up to old fort house it's an
absolutely beautiful view
um and it's you know you can't really
appreciate it when you're driving a car
because you've got focus on the traffic
but if you're walking up that pavement
it is absolutely fantastic
and that's all i'd like to say chair
thank you very much thank you councillor
mcgregor
uh councilman i know that you've had
your hand raised for some time but there
are two other members that would like to
speak and i guess that you will sum up
at the end
is that right yes yeah all right okay
so counselor sorry i
had meant to say previously an important
thing when looking at
working arrangements within fort house
it's important that we remember that the
people there
have to have the best working
environments that they can that we can
provide
but i'm concerned that over the last
year the deterioration in the level of
service that we've had the support that
we've seen
the difficulty in contacting officers
the difficulty again responses to emails
difficulties in getting access to people
at the appropriate time has been
manifest and delayed a lot of the things
that we as councillors should be doing
so the focus should be i think towards
looking at how we provide the best level
of service
to the residents of teen ridge and
support that with the appropriate
conditions for staff and i'd like to
make
have the assurance that when we're
looking at staff working arrangements
we're bearing in mind
uh focus should be towards the levels of
service
as well as the uh environment that we
provide for the staff to work in but i'm
not
happy that we've uh addressed that at
the moment thank you uh
thank you councillor boulevard i know
that councillor hook will will sum up at
the end and i'm sure that she will
embrace some of your
your concerns when she sums up council
patch
uh thank you chair i'd also like to
thank the leader for his um
useful and helpful comments but just by
way of clarification i'm not at all
opposed to um
in principle to the changing of the
layout of fordhaus
and i think we'd all appreciate the
world of work has changed
and it will be very different moving
forward and some
some element of flexible working working
from home
is inevitable my concern is about the
um the pressing forward with what will
be a very expensive
um operation when we haven't had the
full consultation with staff
to see how what appetite there might be
for this
i i'll use the phrase agile working
although i'm not particularly fond of it
i think we should say what it is it's a
it's an element of um working from home
with
other flexibility built in um we're not
sure
exactly what the demand will be um and
i'm not convinced
um well or rather obviously i'm not
going to i say i i am convinced that
maybe
better value for money might be achieved
if we were to
spend some time thinking about this and
come back in
in a month or two having having looked
at what appetite there might be for
staff
and what the options full range of
options might be for forward house
thank you councillor patch councillor
jackie would you like to sum up please
thank you chair um yeah thank you
members for um uh wide-ranging
detailed questions um that's been a
useful debate
um i think i'd like members probably to
to remember and focus on
on what this project is about um so the
two elements one
reducing carbon emissions um and just to
remind you that elements of this were
already
in our capital program so elements of
this money were already in our capital
programme approved earlier this year
and both elements including agile
working will be in our emerging carbon
action plan
um and you know
my mention of the seven thousand pound
per annum saving in energy bills
wasn't meant as the driver of this
obviously
that was an additional bonus to the
project
um beyond its two main aims reducing
carbon emissions and enabling agile
working
um thank you for the comments on the
staff welfare consultation and obviously
the efficient
running of the council all of these uh
paramount considerations and
must be taken into account um going
forward
and yes um really important that we keep
the public informed
um especially because this is partly
about us leading the way
and providing an example of what what
can be done
um so um i hope um after a very long
debate that
members will will approve um
the three recommendations as per the
report with the
addition the amended figure in
recommendation
thank you thank you cancer hook so we
have a proposal from councillor jackie
hook
which has been seconded by councillor
taylor
can we go to the vote please yeah before
we go to the vote could uh
councillor hook just reiterate the
amendment of the sum
just in case any members weren't 100
sure of the
sum of the amendments that's been
reduced isn't it so that's good news
okay so um in recommendation to where
the figure currently reads
2 million seven hundred and twenty one
thousand six hundred and seventy nine
the new figure would be two million
three hundred and sixty eight thousand
and thirty one pounds
approximate reduction of three hundred
and fifty thousand pounds
in terms of borrowing requirements
excellent news
so can we go to the vote please that's a
bradford
all right i couldn't um i
my computer wasn't working at the start
of the meeting so i didn't hear the
start so in that case i must abstain
answer clarence or that's a cold clef
poor cancer connect paul
councillor hugh cox oh
cancer doors
uh i'll abstain
councillor evans four
chancellor foden
that's a goodman bradbury or
that's a gribble four that's the haynes
that's the haze
that's a hocking
council gordon hook or
councillor jackie hook hall
council jefferies four counts of jenks
four cancer
mcgregor like for councillor bulloven i
missed the start of the meeting sal i'm
staying thank you
captain morgan oh that's malone
uh with deep reservations for
cancer nutsley four
council parker khan four
cancer patch against
cancer
against cancer
for cancer rollerson
chairman apologies for missing the first
part of the meeting so i have to abstain
thank you councillor olison that's the
swain
four council taylor
council tomb
councillor wrigley oh
councillor parker four
apologies i believe i missed council
thorne you did yes that's right
i'm against thank you and uh councillor
john petherick
four
thank you for that members that sort of
virtually concludes our meeting for
today
but i just need to advise you that our
next meeting which is the annual council
meeting
will be held on the 28th of may at 10
a.m
at newton abbott racecourse further
details will be advised by the members
newsletter in due course
look forward to seeing you all on the
28th of may
goodbye
thank you chair [ __ ] you chair
and get your